Sebastian lege hat da mal wieder was gebastelt
dafür braucht er hilfe von der feuerwehr
und das alles für den
supermarkt knallhart tütensuppen mit diesem pulver zauber ich ihnen jede suppe und soße diese wollen
was dieses weiße pulver in unseren tütensuppen sucht und was das ganze mit kartoffeln zu tun hat
schauen wir uns mal an
Suppen und saucen aus der tüte gibt es im supermarkt wie sand am meer und überall ist es drin das wunder pulver der lebensmittelindustrie
das sorgt in nullkommanix für himmlische cremigkeit bei jeder suppe und soße es sparte industrie außerdem teure zutaten
und ist geschmacksneutral
ich kann hier alle in einen topf werfen weil es überall das gleiche drin
das zauber pulver will sebastian auch und er trägt der industrie ist einfacher als gedacht
denn bei dem pulver handelt es sich um
kartoffelstärke
dafür braucht sebastian klar kartoffeln genauer den saft da steckt die beliebte stärke bringen
Aber so ist das ganze noch viel zu flüssig
Um daraus ein feines pulver zu machen kommt sebastian selbstgebaute höllenmaschine zum einsatz
eine trocken trommel
abgeht
und zwar so auf der inneren der zwei trommeln wird er stärker saft aufgetragen
mit
ordentliches von außen geht's jetzt rund
jetzt muss es richtig schon getrocknet werden weil wir wollen ja schnee weißes pulver erhalten ansonsten würde es verbrennen
sebastians meisterwerk funktioniert genauso wie die großen industriemaschinen das wasser verdunstet es bleibt feinster stärke stau
Löst sie richtig feines pulver von meiner träume so soll sein
das wunder pulver kann jetzt quasi überall eingesetzt werden gemischt mit wasser quillt die kartoffelstärke auf und eine sämige konsistenz
entsteht die perfekte grundlage für fertigprodukte aus der tüte
sebastian zeigt uns die magie der kartoffelstärke
etwas spargel aroma zum pulver schnittlauch fürs auge ein hauch getrockneter spargel und tada
Fertig ist unser instant spargelsuppe cocktail aus kartoffelstärke
Schmeckt lecker nach spargelsuppe aber in dieser suppe
Der gerade mal so viel spargel
dank des pärchens sparen hersteller bei teuren zutaten spargelsuppe mit nur vier prozent spargel kein problem teure sahne
überflüssig
tatsächlich ist die kartoffelstärke sogar hauptzutat
übrigens das ganze klappt auch hervorragend mit bratensoße
hauptzutat auch hier die magische
kartoffelstärke bei bratensauce sollte man außerdem auf die bezeichnung arten soße zu braten und
bratensoße klingt fast gleich doch der wesentliche unterschied
nur die bratensoße enthält auch wirklich fleisch extrakte in der soße zu braten hingegen stecken nur aromen
Es raschelt
also bei suppen und saucen aus der tüte das nächste mal checken wie viel echte zutaten und wieviel kartoffelstärke drin ist
Nachschlag gefällig auf unserem kanal zdf besser esser gibt's noch mehr tricks checks und duelle aus der welt der lebensmittel